are being brought to you by
proudly celebrating their 90th
anniversary McDonald's what you want is
what you get at McDonald's today
AT&T the right choice and Diet Coke
here's just one just for the taste from
Wayne's World 2 new faces at the Oscars
Dana Carvey and Mike Myers
Wow here we are at the Academy Awards
how exciting yeah very exciting well
pretty tingly all over
imagine you know this time next year you
don't think about it Mike I mean we
could be standing right here accepting
you know I mean an Oscar for uh for best
movie not okay okay that's our stick now
the nominees for a live action short
film are birch Street Gym Stephane
Kessler and Thomas our Conroy last
breeze of summer David M Massey session
man set Winston and Rob free and the
Oscar goes to session man Seth Winston
and Rob free
well thank you very much like to thank
the members of the Academy my mom and
dad and all my friends for their support
over the past few years I'd like to
thank Jenna Memmel Jonathan Sanger Steve
Hewitt and Jim Miller Showtime for
giving me the opportunity to make this
film to thank Jim Gutterman Rob freed my
agent Victoria wisdom and everyone in
the cast and crew
what we achieved together tonight is
really something special
I just like to say hi to my two children
Alexandra and Dashiell who are watching
in England live on the satellite where
it's after five o'clock in the morning
so Alex you might as well stay up all
night thanks a lot I hope everybody gets
a chance to see this movie when it plays
next week on Showtime I'd like to thank
John Dole John Kerry Wood Charisse perch
Rich's Inman Nancy Travis Seth Winston
and mom I don't have time to read the
speech sorry
good luck okay guy okay about the blow
chunks sorry okay
present the next award two of our newest
stars one's a beauty
you know what one's a beast and that's
the only clue we're gonna give you
hmm no so have you seen any of tonight's
nominees no but I read the books the
nominees for animated short subject are
black fly
Christopher Hinton manipulation Daniel
Greaves strings
Wendy Tilby and the Oscar goes to how
gently doing your Thanks it was getting
stuffy in there and the Oscar goes to
manipulation
Daniel grieves
I'd like to thank the following people
the Academy the British Council the
great spike and Mike Sean Barie and
Jed's for all their hard work
and lastly Nigel Emily and my family for
all their support thank you very much
I can't believe that buting the beast
not up for best makeup it's unbelievable
up close